they're still telling people to do this
they're still
presenting the ridiculous basis of all
of the premise of
all of this rioting donald trump is
divisive right
donald trump is a racist no
the obamas were far more racist and far
more divisive than donald trump
and for the one obama that's still in
the in public life
michelle obama she's making that
abundantly clear michelle obama now has
a podcast
everybody's got a podcast everybody
these days has a podcast michelle has a
podcast
in which recently she said that white
people do not
acknowledge that non-white people even
exist take a listen i've had it several
times where i've presented to
members of my team people that i've
worked with peers
go downstairs in the elevator go out to
lunch
and they walk right by you on the street
you're standing in line next to them at
sweet green and they look right through
you they assume they don't
know you they have no use for you
and yet you just help solve their legal
problem or
help make them some money or save them
some money but then
when you're out in the world you're just
an invisible
person what is she saying here
specifically she's saying
i people that i would work with didn't
want to socialize with me outside of
work
it must be because they're racist it
must be because they're bigots
you ever think maybe it's you you ever
think maybe you
are a little unlikable you ever think
that you or you this woman who says i've
never loved my country i've never been
proud of my country until it elected my
husband
you who are saying all white people are
racist because they don't see black
people
who speak in these awful divisive tones
you ever think maybe it's you
maybe it's not the color of your skin
it's just that
you're not likable you're not a likable
person because you're contemptuous of
everybody else
no that's not possible right she goes
beyond work she talks about this
experience she had
this great slight she had as first lady
in an ice cream shop that proves
systemic racism when the girls were
little
this is when i was first lady i am
michelle obama the first lady of the
united states
of america of america and we had just
finished the taking the girls to a
soccer game we were stopping to get ice
cream
and there was a line and once again when
i'm
just a black woman i noticed that white
people don't even see me
they're not even looking at me so i'm
standing there
with two little black girls another
black female adult they're in
soccer uniforms and a white woman cuts
right in front of us to order like she
didn't even see us
now so i stepped up and i said excuse me
i said you don't see us four people
standing right here you just jumped in
line she didn't apologize she
never looked me in my eye she didn't
know it was me
does anybody seriously believe that
while michelle obama was the first lady
of the united states
someone didn't recognize her at the ice
cream shop around where she lives
does anybody seriously believe that no
of course not so what does this amount
to what
what is the scene they're in an ice
cream shop
and someone they're waiting somewhere
and then someone
goes ahead in line and then michelle
obama says hey
i'm waiting here and then the woman
backs away
but doesn't you know talk to her or
anything doesn't look at her
has that ever happened to you regardless
of the color of your skin or anything
like that
anyone ever accidentally cut you in line
or maybe you're in a shop and
they're not sure are you waiting for
your order or have you ordered yet and
someone goes ahead of you has that ever
happened
of course it happens all the time i'm
not saying every time you go into a
restaurant or a shop or an ice cream
shop
but a lot of the time have you ever cut
someone accidentally
yeah i have i did it like two weeks ago
and then let's say that that person you
cut
this this woman who makes damn well sure
you know i'm the first
lady of the united states of america of
america i'm the first lady michelle
obama
i'm so important i'm so wonderful listen
to my podcast read my book all about me
my favorite subject
you think maybe you might be a little
intimidated you might you might not make
you might not be the most gregarious
person there maybe you don't make eye
contact
when you're talking to one of the most
powerful people in the world you ever is
that possible
no no it can't be just a personal just a
slight not just actually not a personal
side it's a racial slight because
they're all racist
because they're all out to get you
michelle michelle obama the greatest
victim in the history of the world
michelle obama the rich famous beloved
former first lady of the united states
after this horrible racist nation
elected her husband president
twice because of how racist it is they
sure fooled them oh man they didn't
realize he's a black guy
because they're so racist they would
never elect a black guy right they would
never give her
zillions of dollars to read her stupid
book or listen to her stupid podcast
oh no wait a minute the reality is
completely the opposite
completely the opposite doesn't matter
though this grievance narrative man that
sure sells books
talk to robin deangelo talk to the white
fragility people or
any of these other race hustlers it
sells a lot this grievance thing sells a
lot of books
and so that's what we focus on rather
than have gratitude
for our country which abraham lincoln
famously tells us in the lyceum address
is the only way that we're going to
preserve our country is to have
gratitude and reverence for our founding
for our institutions
even the greatest beneficiaries of those
institutions
and of that founding and in this country
some of the most powerful privileged
people
in the entire country they tear it down
you know it just it sells better sounds
but feels so good
to do that i hope you enjoyed that short
segment from the michael knowles show be
sure to check out the full episode
linked in the description
or download the podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
you